good evening everybody members
welcome to development in 1850 February
2018 started with emergency evacuation
announcement should you be required to
evacuate the building would you please
leave the building by the nearest
available exit the chamber or assembly
point is in a public car park outside of
the Civic suite please don't delay your
graduation to collect any belongings
please don't return to the building of
asking permission to do so by councils
remember council staff we please also
remember that this meeting is the audio
recorded but if you've got your mobile
please apologies for absence I have been
received from Council mrs. Foy 55
counselor mrs. Mason
you can cancel amount in place they
delayed our Hospital has been
substituted by counselor mr. Mason
we were also anticipating a speaker mr.
Clark as an objector unfortunately he's
been delayed on the trains and is
unlikely to make it however on 6.11 9
it's the letter that he's written in so
cover his points before we go any
further as well can I just ensure that
everybody has received the addendum it
circulated okay very much non-members
attending we have counts the lovely
council 0 item 4 is the minutes of the
meeting held on 25th and after January
2018 miss miss I know is as the correct
record of that meeting thank you I can't
find these declarations of interest
item number six
obviously we've seen this before but
members have had a letter from mr.
Thomas outlining the reason why its back
before us and essentially were rerunning
the whole event from scratch with
working technology so revenants please
the evening than this right so cool
arose through these flights so there we
are we've got a cyclic ation plan there
just to run through the application
sites which is no 3.2 hectares is the
Kaizen and also London Road almost ops
of the generation of the mini writing
right to make the plant recite a setback
and higher than possibly 90 meters it's
impossible for single service and repair
all open benefits rate supports and the
source of outbuildings here is amongst
it Gandhi's the northern portion of the
site is yep 40 species in the main the
but basically it's false paths that the
pencils allocated ser walnut allocation
there's fast application site includes
and our projections the open land to the
west of the name all do the site which
is this projection yeah
the site includes Valley Street
presentational the Sonics normally
boundaries defined by a broker to the
boardwalk right the application size is
defined to include the main site access
from London Road the ones who nine
currently the local authorities
ownership and have the existing access
the site access is shared with two holes
located between main 799 application
segment and the raw
the remainder land between the main path
the statement and run comprises a
residential for the SACNAS
come close and also claim on present by
now it's been developed along to the
east of application state medical the
aware falls public on western boundary
the disappeared really and predominantly
comprises residential estate development
most lanten's north and west of
application that has come the
undeveloped and also for path with
dementia presidential and application
SVR wall they need lee to the west of
the site of buildings and plainly fields
use for the sports the social club
really sports a social club and so this
is quite important in terms of the
location of the sports and social club
because there's an issue of compensation
patent which is covered in the report
there's a piece of two separate tiny
consent people just like - that'd be
great baby the site service members will
see isn't there's not all times and it
read out it's in this area here it's for
supporters yet
so from countywide str1 allocation the
removals are swiped three these right
this plan is a plan which has been
enacted by officers to our understanding
of the relationship to the applications
like uneven residential development
Implanon presents the postulate is being
completely collected they need and
speaker between this meeting so in terms
of the layout of the site we'll go
through that but this is the plan on
present one of the properties so members
are can appreciate a close physical
affiliation between the application site
and the residential development to the
east the plan five six yr portability to
be the role play outs within the
development the layers of all of us
eventually units on those sources
immunity spaces to give the location of
public open space and landscaping well
access will be will be clearly slopped
up which is this access here in favor of
the retention of this access which also
all the access to the really sports and
social club there were concerns
initially that this access road here
would be so
we built our key which is now being
addressed by the separate planning
application to provide car parking
within the adjacent site this language
is false plan to the previous access for
London Road and originally proportionate
and packings are saying which will be
actually this rule that's that's will be
slopped up here will be a lit walkway so
this will not be submit to any care
packing arrangements and it will be
providing access for pedestrians to
London or on the site without having to
negotiate the main access road to the
site broad widths within the government
indicated these six meters with 1.5 2
meter wide foot ways we've got offices
the main spine roll coming in with
offshoots so the the natural width
overall is a 6 meter wide roared with
1.5 to 2 meter wide foot twenties with
side roads being five point eight meters
widths and 1.5 meter wide for trace this
provision is on a par with recent
developments including those that owns
at the former a on site which provides
similar board widths of five point six
five meters why to interface with shared
space providing a road with the mention
of five point seven for further
comparisons can be drawn with a breeze
leading development where access to the
site to six point seven is white with
two metre wonderful toys which shared
spacing the flight went eight nine
meters
furthermore the Christmas tree farm and
Hall compromises four point ninety two
wide access with 2 meter foot sways and
shared service rates
like when take for the whole war
development wise an axis and spine rod
width of the 626 with 2 meter wide for
tweeze and the shank surface of opening
- that's just to draw a comparison basin
in terms of what members will be able to
ascertain for themselves in terms of
broad widths etc so what we have in
terms the development specificity shrink
it down slightly as well very well
though in terms of the development
itself
I will show you mid slides of showing
the specific locations or specific types
of housing but generally speaking as we
looking about site layout of plan
all of our plans have been indication
really is is that the open space is
located at the top of the site at the
northeast corner we have an area of
planning which is a very strong physical
boundary that will be retained in the
site and this is aligned with the area
where packages with the Badger centers
and then we have this reisel and that is
going out to the west that will
potentially serve as a linkage to the
approved sites further 500 development
there so in terms of what members can
ascertain from that site plan at least
what we have is we've got to - that
we've got to remember to both houses 25
3 that houses 14 all bedroom houses 3
number 5 bedroom faces 29 one day flats
including for white all the galleries
units we have 10 in under two-bedroom
flats and erection on three in number of
poor supported and living units and
these supportive living
zoom in a little bit that means the
bottomless lakes of southeast corner of
the site so the K all currently they're
moving aligning with the sort of the
model of Canada fitara support be
providing in future opportunities been
taken to reappraise the scheme and this
is obvious units fourteen fifteen
sixteen are easier so really this form
they're integrated into the development
in a way that doesn't believe me the
supported living appear as a as an
institutionalized don't form really so
that that is worth pointing that out
this also parking landscaping he
mentioned that stopping up of existing
access so the plan is no net of the
State Road with parking of residential
accommodation providing off services
allergies and car ports so basically
what we have the flat is India there's
four blocks of 880 units within each
block and parking is provided within
this area here with separate amenity
space open space here with advocate back
down as the serve all the properties
well cover that and there's a lot from
the addendum that we have now produced
technical guidance comparisons and
assessments of the garden space
if the majority that report facts we
definitely thought walks will pay for
the northern parts of the site these
will provide accommodation of the three
floors for the top floor each mark
incorporated in the roof space
in addition tour number four in number
one baking flax or the damages will be
provided the new houses would be two
storeys in height of all some wood will
include roof level accommodation
surveyed on the windows Mena's variables
appreciate access we show the elevation
and street scenes the pointing is being
mentioned we want to slide please there
we go
so what this this is a site analysis
plan and what this planning in the case
is the the different forms of
developments here so what we have is the
green of the the supportive living unit
which have four bedroom units the back
orange our two-story properties banana
college so what we have here is we've
got terrorists properties here typically
we've got three and four and five
bedroom property here the blue of the
flat or the guarantee guarantee
accommodation and then for lots of flats
further to the north of the site the
amenity parking analysis plan - the plan
to the right-hand side of the screen
what what this actually indicates is the
parking areas of the steam which
demonstrate compliance with the
requirements of SPD - as such related to
a garden area vision that's all for some
price
meaning entities is provided between
flats 46 47 48 and 49 which of these
units here the flats or the garages so
in terms of the importance of complies
with with garden aerospace what the
figures now through the addendum
demonstrate this is 100% compliance with
the requirements and the requirements
basically is that it's a 25 square meter
per flap ratio and it does actually
exceed that ratio the woman's who bathed
in the flats also served by human
community space which exceed the minimum
requires us that's like an SPD to this
provisions in the kit in an addendum
page sagnik members wanted to refer to
that likewise a technical house a
standard assessment has also been
undertaken and is included on page also
includes it on the appended them so
we'll just show members note the
affordable housing allocation
what this pen space is that the
affordable housing comprised of readings
and weddings members will not also put
the addendum that officers have received
feedback from the strategic closing
theme on the suitability of homes enix
so just to confirm to them there's what
we have is about in terms default or mix
we have these are the terrace properties
we have a talk there's we've got two
times five eight six person units four
times to bed four-person units to tends
to be better or person units and four
times feedback Tiger Salinas and U is
fifty five to eighty six which in
totality of these strategies all the
flats are basically affordable so
members are not from the addendum of
thirds of conspiracy that's the
producing team basically as satisfying
didn't have any adverse comments in this
respect so in terms of complaints with
the authority of miss each form of the
plan on the plan it implies so I'll just
move all no members to show you some
street scenes the first scene at the top
is a cross-section from east to west
looking from the north of plots that 88
to 48 and 49 the second section below
what have you got there old we've got
slate six that weakness
it's like six yeah the second section
that we have here members this section
here is a section is a continuation of
that street scene along the way around
to the west of the site so basically if
you were standing north looking at the
other fall units for example this is the
is that is the section which is it which
is along that radial arm moving on from
the fall units I think those the twofold
unis wax or the garbages the third
section of the bottom here is looking
from east to west from the tips for
support units of what 22 which has we
bedroom property so if one was at the
east of the site looking from these
extra support units towards the west
that is the the end point of plot seven
there so if your idea of the other
speakers feel of the streets and we move
on to slide seven please the fourth
section is the view looking at plot
central angle from the east from the
area in front of the fitara support
units again have a look which is this
one here yeah
so then Senor fielding flights on the
palliative materials of Central and what
I would say is in terms the master
landscape plan I do consider that the
trees that are shown within the within
the street scenes actually true visual
representations of the scheme once those
keys have reached a certain age of
maturity so to find them this section
here what this section shows is a view
looking west from across the main spine
or taking in the current building and
the fronted buildings so this is a this
is a view basically looking at the at
the flats right at the top of the site
finally on section six shows the view
the fact it blocks from the east for the
public open space right okay so in terms
of all members can ascertain from that
really all I want to serve members the
take from that is there's a what will
striking is there are a number of sort
of design features there are hip rooms
there are roof flights there are there
are sub like jetty little D black
features it's quite an interesting
scheme in terms the mix part materials
blender brick lots of glass and you can
notice the actual design it's not two
square windows the the fenestration
sensor wants to move the rhythm of the
of the room for wine etc so that's one
interesting feature move on to slide a
in please these are the visions they
what the salvation is is the
its Lloyd support for bed units and just
give members maybe of the scale of this
beam tool
the actual eaves level here is only two
point four above ground level so they're
quite its described within the with the
housing analysis plan as the chalet
bundle type development leads to the
green on the previously shown plan and
the actual height of the building
actually is six point five meters
concern musics expressed this would be
the elevation that would be actually
facing the bungee wall with Claremont
Crescent so in terms of any potential
will be looking from this dwelling at
least into lemon crescent that just
would not be possible due to the design
so I do feel like the designers being
particularly responsive to Nittany Tony
all the looking slight nine response a
slight line the slight line is that is
the flat above GABA Kunis what members
mean normally the slight Shan is it's
basically an underpass into a real core
to our parking area it has got
interesting sort of concept there just
to give a variety to the design really
so just so it's a good makes basically
and flats hang difficult slight tank so
just to give you an idea this these the
flattest needs basis at least so to
stick an idea of the range of heights
the the flats in terms of like then is
ten meters in height so it ranges from
six point five from the district's aport
units to ten meters in height which of
the three story quantity the slaver land
is the refuse storage in collection
clarity further clarity has been salt on
this matter
widely from the applicants in terms of
refuge storage in collection what the
supply seeks to demonstrate is the
tracking of Mali movements throughout
the site in terms of in terms of
accessing the
refuse storage areas and what the
applicants has done is be blue but
angular areas the North's within the
sites where storage bins of them have
been stored and the point of collection
of two short little stars here so what
would actually demonstrates is that
throughout the site due to the geometry
and width of the rule but there will be
no issues in terms of a being or me
accessing the collection points and in
terms of the importance is is that the
bin collection point so right on the you
know in terms of in easy access of the
curve site needs to be other than tucked
away behind the immunity space so that
is we have sought some advice here from
our colleagues in recycling and in
principle and these schemes available
subject to further these four things
submitted just mean that site so the the
feedback we received is that it's
acceptable but further details of the
neatly submitted I'm gonna be covered by
condition of the being of offices in
this matter actually members will know
that the matter of refuse collection
which were quite clarification was
coverton estates in point six point five
of the of the report so I'm going to
move on now members two key
considerations before closing my
presentation so the key considerations
as far as I'm concerned as follows the
consideration of the proposals against
the National Planning person framework
and development plan on my members of
the subcommittee to attend the tikar
seasons in strict accordance with the
provisions of the development plan as is
required others by section 38 six of the
coming as we purchase active version or
and then basically the resolution is in
favor of sustainable development which
is regards the golden thread running
through all plan making and the decision
making precisely proposal that accord
with the development plan should be
approved both delay where a development
plans after census filings are where
other than positive out-of-date Planning
Commission's be granted unless any
adverse impacts of doing sort would
consider to complete and then most of
the only outweigh the benefits whence
the when assess against the policy
industry as at all so much as a broad
overview that members will be aware of
buying these opponents who so you like
that that's in support so in terms of
the core principles laid outs and which
underpin the National Mining force of
green work we just move on to to assess
in the pinion of officers how this
application actually meets policy pretty
new year
so members will notes that the
application has been supported by a
number of supplementary documents
- economist all of them and the purpose
of these documents of Z from the onset
is to demonstrate that the application
and propose the government accord with
planning policy of national and local
level within the design max's statements
that are called to report a landscape
master plan we have an ecological impact
assessments and focused assessment which
within that assessment in appendix G
everything's a service water management
plan so in terms of the fact is the
basis of the decision of F the makers on
the basis of the evidence that is
promoted to put forward by those
documents so I'm just gonna conclude
members buying the exaggerating a few
points the application has supported by
further information in officers opinion
it's demonstrated that the proposed
units in sciency complies with all those
policies highlighted on the page six
point one one three of the reports the
scheme is in accordance with provision
of the development plan normal to a
planning considerations indicates
otherwise the new access design and
layout of the government is considered
in many respects exemplar following
consider work and design improvements in
conjunction less expensive Council that
have been designed to esses companies
ice support the scheme Essex County
Council how you would support the scheme
the Lord Laird complies with a
pocketable standards and the Essex
design right the scheme provides
affordable housing in accordance with
policy the scheme complies with the
space standards as included on the
appendices and the addenda flooding
Essex sucks believed authority does not
subject the scheme the leaflet authority
has no concern that the steam cannon see
that greenfield water run operates such
that the fall from the site is Norbury
it's active development in current
English news place and basically
this service water management plan is
covered in appendix G of the Bloodless
assessment and the conclusions reached a
6-point notes of the report and that is
the basis on which Essex certs have
confirmed their acceptability there is
one section of the report the conclusion
which perhaps is rather misleading and
it was an unfortunate choice of words
but what we have recently then last
couple days from sons I will read the
site to members as you rightly said over
the Lord we did object-- the Consol of
the stuff we we did not object the
principle of the strategy this was based
on the information that was provided in
support of this application as it was
demonstrated that the scheme could be
delivered in line with our requirements
this remember be a sort of further
examination of the core of the required
detailed information that has been
requested as part of the condition we
look for you other to support and an
objection was placed on the application
of the stage of the planning process as
some of the information required to
carry out detailed assessments but not
be reasonably expected until the
application for progress to the next
stage of the process and that sort of
love email actually tries to encompass
and encapsulate the whole issue of the
surface water drainage is that the
principles of of people's foresight and
Walter attenuation from the site which
is going to be achieved by three main
means which is and the provision of
filter drains alleviation storage
impervious surfaces so these strategy
has already been put forward in the
focused assessments in appendix G and in
principle what what the leaf of the
float is saying is although perhaps we
don't
you should eat salt that is requite at
this stage that is not a relevant
consideration because the principle of
it that the technical dates and the more
believe us and undertaken does
demonstrate that we will be able to
achieve it but the conditions are needed
to to ensure that it does deliver in
accordance with your thesis against such
AI in the infant risk analysis that's
the best way I can explain that so we'll
move on
just before I conclude and pass back to
the chair
be culturally assess service which
assesses the impress of the development
flora and fauna conclude that no species
present on site including amphibians
reptiles and mammals all plant species
will be adversely affected by the
development which has an earlier
thorough assessment of these impacts in
informing 18 its occasion measures
including these live including the safe
dance to the Badger set during the
course of development naturally one has
no objection and that's on page six
point two six of report so the cloud is
new provider name in connection the
storage bins the tree replacement plan
is a two for one ratio is considered
acceptable subject the plumbing
munitions highlighted additional
requirements members have noted that the
in the addendum in terms additional
requirements which relates a healthcare
provision and the provision of place
space such as the recommendation is the
recommendation is a revised
recommendation of approval subjects to
immediately these pegs of terms a B and
C in the report
the initial heads of terms the undie in
the addendum which rates the NHS and
play equipment and the further hesitancy
actual to deliver car parking to the
very sports or social club which has
been approved and repairing this
application so it cannot be in tune
there's a condition as it's not home
park application site so officers are
recommending condition F the no sorry a
further terms of peasant service act to
achieve the come to deliver the car
parking at the sports and social club
and so the condition so sites in the
report and to a further condition
so quite a submission of details of the
provision of breakfast pins and
enclosures for the fronted buildings in
the city group thank you thank you just
one of the small bit of information that
was some confusion about the naming of
swing Park and down or Laura age six
point one one five clarifies that was a
you know speaker mr. my twin ladies
speak on behalf of the applicant
that's not five minutes do you think I
might turn me up need property managers
or Fitzroy
firstly Fitzroy is a non-profit charity
but we need to transform the lives of
people with learning disabilities will
now start the salary and we are governed
by non pension trustees a high priority
for us absolutely high priority for us
is to be negative neighbour wherever we
are but beyond to the application itself
I speak on behalf of Fitzroy and family
developments we vocals with our own
detailed report prepared by offices we
just probably constructively to the
issues raised by Essex and/or the
council offices probably the submission
of the application the scheme has been
amended in variety of constructive
feedback from offices throughout the
site itself comprises a mix of
brownfield land and advocated by the
Council for residential use the proposal
provides an early contribution to the
policy expectation agreeing a minimum of
500
on-site SEO on bumper boats also
provides the policy component level how
many and a good mix of wedding types and
clearly many family homes but they often
scare them how this ensures that all the
proposed dwellings received satisfactory
levels of daylight Sun right now within
the privacy the proposal also provides a
new carrier combination to replace the
existing registered care home have a tip
the road which is on the side and that
is not fit for modern convertibles this
will alter from a single to three
supported living shadows by virtue of
two things firstly the Care Quality
Commission the CQC which to minimize the
size of any new registered matters this
would be and secondly as its council
commissioners wish to move away from
register care into a supportive living
environment energy with me
in fact these burglars will become a
seamless and unassuming perfect that
engages in constructive into occupied
delinquency of some of the land for
housing enable us to be able to provide
independence with the support we've
submitted is a body of technical
informations all said yes
including focus information ecology
highways and parking trees and transient
heritage a detailed surface water
drainage management strategies being
provided and officers proposed the
drainage management scheme itself is
addressed through pre commencement
condition the technical evidence does
confirmed the proposals would not
increased flooding and objects has been
raised by the depot in response to
requests from officers we also provided
details of refuse and recycling which
you've seen already and how vehicles
will access all areas we've also
provided officers for the commitment to
deliver an on-site children's play area
and associated equipment we've indicated
this facility could be located on the
northern part of the site in the open
space but it's detailed design and
location would be subject to the section
106 agreement let the car park leaders
within the scene pretty comprehensive
learning standards as the officer's
report confirms all spaces that can be
located in relation to the properties of
those things so
the Badger says is fully protected
during the construction stage Raworth
mitigation and protection measures
described in the occupation of the new
home design will be finalized between us
with condition 5 and finally there was
some concern raised initially over the
number of planning conditions which you
know have you ever not successive
developments on this society so many
dishes could actually be combined as two
conditions effectively deal with one
imagining places but there are no
conditions for inconsiderate
understanding and we actually welcomed
the own going over signed these
conditions will provide for offices and
ongoing development thank you very much
thank you mister power for through
developed isn't it time I've mentioned
for number three were delayed appointed
seventy or written submission but others
say now yeah we've got your five minutes
you know firstly I'd like to say how
disappointed I am it's been brought back
to committee and so it's I can't believe
it
how can these playoffs leave their
doubts but additional anxiety it
stresses people's lives as mentioned in
my first speech they have no regards for
the concerns of people at this town if
anything news comes tonight tonight I've
just walked into something new that was
different to there the first person and
any dish waiters in the additional
documents we should be made aware and
the meeting postpones with our
consultation the great news about being
brought back to committee is I get to
answer some of the plan the officers
quite comments from the first meeting I
don't like the process where my queries
come in on it after I have spoken and I
can't challenge airplanes following this
and our failures can be unacceptable and
outside the rules of natural justice so
answer a few points for the last meeting
the trees are even poorer repair Oh
the trees are older than you I'm really
confident in you whether you rainy I
like you stop analyzing on Google Earth
maybe your pitches a bit grainy I know
your great variety indeed also competing
with me
and it's email you a person in like
forward to cancer which is more pressing
issues pictures shows you know take out
of town seriously and I probably know
casing wells to downplay and officer I
won't go to project we pleased assorted
wells at all corners of England when we
need to be in London as I was today
muster we're in London when you need to
be ready you should be maybe that you
will know maybe thing you would know the
trees and thoughts in disrepair you
would also know that and on the road
desperately needs across it it's unsafe
to to traffic traveling at high speeds
and not adhering to the person on our
speed it due to a lack of signage you
may also know if the care home is not in
keeping with local properties as stated
at the last meeting it is oversized and
disagreements they walked in as well it
is oversized over very
and that's our enjoyment of my home and
garden and that my neighbors
you will also be correctly cook you also
feels correctly quotes surrounding
properties to the site and I'll be
correcting if you make that same mistake
again tonight in the trades rainy you
make your breeding time to redesign guys
and see it it's not been fired by
message to refute on this much of this
recount so he's gonna stop trying to
mediate argue about its highlights in my
house on the website and under the
screen tonight
and did you clearly know my houses I
don't can't pay a visit and tell you
where the kid home sick
that's the car kind of just stop you for
a moment
ladies yeah could you refrain from
personally attacking the officers can
you talk about that that position rather
than myself
well this is to fit stories if you want
to know your home is clear maybe look
outside right we don't want your point
design how how these we don't put the
24-hour pieces next to me our houses we
don't want to hit and being site behind
our garden we don't want the noise from
deliveries and star from I believe in
twenty four hours a day
we don't want the neighbors have no
regard for the community and those were
the folk my speech to postpone regulate
their points and I guess only skiers
rejects proposal against tonight thank
you thank you
don't have a visiting members mr. turn
this is lovely
the congestion and pedestrian safety in
Hungary
I've been told about it yes I see it
every day
the normal foot ways in the north side
are inadequate pedestrians to pulse
pushchair mobility scooter without
stepping into the busy breath there are
too many junctions in close proximity to
this application of sign on a very busy
street for so many junctions highway
safety both residents and drivers is a
real concern traffic has difficulties so
right from little weenie chase into
London Road the bus trip into the Buster
there is a very busy primary school in
Italy to chase traffic off refused to
turn right into the blocking the road
and The Times is also killing to enter
the garage from the direction of the car
between Victoria Avenue and Italy DJ's
opposite the BP garage with a man
suspenseful now there is no safe place
that pedestrians to cross the man will
own and access all the services and
pedestrians that he doesn't have taken
by highways in this location which did
not meet the criteria for crossing at
that time in 2014 that pedestrian refuge
was installed and this is not a safe
place to wait to cross back a narrow
stretch of road since then the very
successful Marks & Spencer store at the
garage is attracting pedestrians across
from the Southside
we try to stay on to the Megadrive
estate to access the service
children confused by this application
to reach applications timeless
for a previously approved development on
land adjacent to claim villa pisani my
57 properties which may or may not be
delivered in time soon
yes it's Highway Authority consultation
response in January 2016
I led to the requirement by the bluefin
crossing in this location this led to a
condition of approval that latter
occupation of the development the
developers shall be responsible for the
provision of pedestrian crossing on
London Road to include where appropriate
drop curb crossings and provision of the
tuna to put weight on the southern side
of the road to link into the existing
port wave on the chains and associated
structures if development has not
this would not happen and not at least
not anytime soon but this application
to be determining the statement which is
for a much larger development the nature
three properties very close both being
judged on its own merit by this
Authority it does not see the need for
an agreement for pedestrian crossing in
the same
it may be the fourth time to this site
previously coming to
the speaker
much smaller element properties I
understand that this application will be
considered and determined on the basis
the fact that the type of consideration
consideration regardless the
requirements the previous scheme which
may or may not
and then or cannot be relied upon to
we are told the team
phenomena soon as possible so while
we're not asking for a conditional
provision across
I relax a contribution for pedestrian
crossing from misty
thank you
that's the step W in the pension for us
I just want to watch clarification could
we have up the slight layer
we
okay in the top corner there there's a
square area which I'm suing is some sort
of talk or something
okay just not quite what that is please
do you mean this give me this area here
now for the deal yeah that's it that's
the girl Michelle that is phenomenal
space to serve these two sets of
flattened schemes and if we go down to
the bottom of their door and again
please keep going
you've got the leg that comes down which
appears to go nowhere
yeah that's it yeah you've said I think
we've said there that there was a
footpath through there does that
actually live right through to the open
road it'll be a pedestrian spot where
Lynne's pedestrian it's okay so it
actually it does actually leave my
restaurant that's not clear from Troy I
just bring the door down a little bit
okay with car park is for the sport
center a lot of that man reflects its
o'clock is that a reasonably close there
would there be any form of acoustic
fixing the longest area landscaping from
noise that may occur from parking
evening parking that's with E Y to be
done so that in terms of landscaping
scheme I don't recall from the reporters
it's a lengthy report in terms of
intensity you think of the know where
potentially always take things not
marking because now they may be far
enough away from the door it was a
specific point in terrific fencing that
was lay that way and he just a troponin
C and in terms of our considerations
offices I don't think there's any
landscaping plan that actually specifies
that but they may be scope within the
planning conditions to require further
details about the arena's travel and
speaking speed possibly might be an idea
just a little concerned about the party
yes it's almost did raise a point that
this all seemed remotely I think did ask
for it
okay
okay that's fine and my final point is
doing 28 Sully the photo point in the
green area at the top of me northeast
corner the cycle thing that's it will
there be any play equipment provided by
the developer for use so in the latter
recommendation and the the the
additional heads of terms D and E then
fact that it's proposed that other these
sort of need to be finalized it would be
within this designated open space people
forced incited okay what I would like to
suggest to is that with the play
equipment to make Whitman that's some
open air gym equipment for suicide more
mature Julie thank you Dad for mrs.
Mason
I think that's good University that I'm
sure you can hear me this application
was presented to the development
committee only length of January we
considered on the basis of the report
presented and it was resolved
unanimously it's been confused but as
the oral presentation with me today is
intended due to IT difficulties to
research application the application was
circulated unchanged the next day three
weeks later
last night I received a 10 page addendum
it is regretted that the thermal
information that was provided today was
not included in an updated report or an
addendum
having said that our policy on to the
application in general our policy as
being that affordable housing should be
35% of the mix of properties and not 35%
in the smallest and pepper potted around
any development site the report in the
attended showing that the delay in
supply from the calculations of needs
that may vary in the case approach is 7
years for the first delivery are still
not completed we'll demonstrate that
using our current applications
requirement it's not an efficient method
of anticipating demand that a mix of
properties should be provided I believe
this name has been addressed however the
application was refused twice due to a
fortune
housing concerns and yet it is still an
unspecified in writing and left to the
officers to determine had a very we've
had a verbal report that has given us
informations but it's not pepper wanted
you can see that that is not pepper
words and these should not the condition
they should have been altered to reflect
the updated information that has been
given to us verbally the time is the
11th of January has not been used to
reduce existing conditions that though
this was a concern raised in the
previous debate it was stated for my
office's that government advices but
we're possible conditions should be kept
to a minimum
also reinforced at this point because it
has not been done or altered it needs to
be period I assume that a government
advise is to allow members to have put
understanding involvement which is a
decision-making process the concerns
still abate and they are concerns
there's there's still some query about
they've been collection points though it
has been clarified the report from the
design Nexus statement says that they
don't think with some of the access the
there is still you haven't been
addressed the determination of safe
walking and cycling routes to schools or
clarification over the possible
provision
crossing we haven't got the lack of 19th
edition of street parking has not been
mentioned in lack of any state to
prevent surface water runoff during
construction and conveyed pollution has
not been covered and I can't see covered
in conditions I'm sure obviously correct
me if I'm wrong the lack of water and
the consultation due to the confusion
over the wall has not been addressed or
correct see the details of the
affordable housing is justified
diversified was setting the conditions
not the information were being given
here
so unfortunately concerns about I won't
going on to be difficult using it
because generally speaking like there is
those problems of money but I also feel
they should have been addressed before
we came here again however we haven't
probably have an application which I'm
sure I've been around the site I'm sure
many other people say our hearts say we
want to approve we really want to
program we know than these the pair hug
residents and how desperately they need
but this is a planning planning
committee and there's still many aspects
albeit minor but I really could that
should be addressed before the
application practice committing my
concerns something we don't forget last
minute but ma'am please like that
something original concern address
information would be to abuse
application as we haven't got adequate
information I don't want to do and I
know that's my head so what I'm going to
propose and I know this would be a
particularly popular decision run if the
committee might consider to firming this
application for the applicant to address
the issues based on the specified amount
I'm sure there'll be other issues other
members praise so they could be
addressed with offices and with the
broadcaster's because of the problem
over the listening of the wall from both
down the road and smoke Park range so
that in commanders can being bold as
they should have been and those issues
can be present
it can come back to us with points of
concern address as some happen today
fully address so that members can be
fully comfortable with proving this
report so I move for divert councillor
Newport
Sharon our second demo
the news about newish state
hey Jack counselor mrs. Masons have it
most of the ones I think can erase save
me and one thing I would like some
clarification on though was with the
Beanstalk
maybe we'll bring that slide back out of
place
so ism is the bin store for the care
home against the fence which backs onto
the gardens and place
[Music]
the right question be big thing to serve
unit 16 units 16 there's a separation
distance about three meters between the
gable end of unit 16 so that's the
precedent categorically no the bill you
will not be against the fence because
this to a scale would represent three be
evens pop down to the side of the unit
so there's nothing actually go against
the fence of the of the boundary with
Clemens present okay okay so I'm a bit
concerned if their commercial bins in
the summer could be pretty smelly for
someone sitting in their garden that's
just one point in order to raise and one
of the other points of I wanted to see
them speak about it was the provision of
processes make something alumni's
or the provision across it this is a
very important point because pavement on
the northern side of London Road is very
narrow in places now those people that
are in those care homes I assume they're
not going to be
some of them may be in wheelchairs and
I've got very concerns about there's no
crossing it's a little possible aside
from the rate we're safer to walk we'll
be pushing the wheelchair and I think
they would be struggle to be questioned
among the papers on that side some of
whom may have disabilities so you need
to look to aggress you cannot walk to
oppress at some points on the London
Road I witnessed that myself and care is
making everyone to step out onto the
road it is a very very important point
to note and the provision of a crossing
should this be approved is a must in my
opinion the other thing that the last
point I wanted to make was in the last
when this came before committing that so
council cut more needs of the council's
here and he lambasted the officers for
lack of water members consultation and
still that hasn't appeared but I've just
don't understand why thank you
just a name thank Jenny
I'm not to draw your attention to the
core strategy before adoptions look
impeccable primer page 55 in where we
turn by the side you will apply this
equation test and direct developmental
areas at least risks of flooding we will
apply the exceptions test when the
sequential test has shown that there are
no and I'm sure that the officer is
quite familiar with that paragraph so in
that in that light and from what's being
sent from the in as much as there are
conditions and a lot of conditions that
there are a lot of conditions that there
are and we still haven't I haven't seen
anything to do with that before they
stopped building I'd like to bring them
to your attention
normal water courses and right parent
ownerships
if you don't know about them anything
nor from government that has
but they see if you love my parent own
properties or [ __ ] subject to any
statutory modifications to live in the
wet to require that nothing is done to
effect the prejudice either by quality
or quantity of the morals as it flows in
its natural state the original
appearance of the property proprietors
are compared only so far as the
reasonable exercise of statutory rights
this Georgia Court on the occupied land
is under no obligation to prevent water
that has come naturally into the lake
and it and has not been artificially
retained there from party into the lower
leg not just the Johnson but because
it's driven teas into the water courses
however the lower occupy is under no
obligation to receive them that's
somebody you probably don't need to read
out can i doing judicial this is
judicial law and so basically have the
off table throws the question had the
officers judicial north even in relation
to flood Prevention's and if they
haven't I suggest that they do because
there was a lot there where we have
mistakenly we're not done it in the past
in the way of the drawings
prices for parky in other areas for
broadening and I suggest that they look
at this before they enter any more into
it
okay okay yeah by two bowls or so I like
to come back on that point so in terms
of the a sheet in which which is basic
information of the focused assessment to
address that belief to that concern is
raised in terms of sequentially sections
that it needs all the text because it's
another case it's like that doesn't come
to meet the exceptions tax that's
funding law that's not other more data
planning law so in terms of the tests
are met that's it over to me and that's
the end of the matter
I've been help members with this
consultation then this will be familiar
from time to time we get applications
that have some size whereby or some
nature and characteristic the anticipate
that the members will be in receipt of
phone calls as soon as the application
it connects we do we remember in dates
the Bible use decision copies of the
application nowadays we notify you in
existence of the application so it's
really the members heads-up because
during the life of the application
typically first few weeks members will
give advise will get approached by by
their community as to what they know
about it
and if they can help them etcetera that
the consultation is in effect is a
notification to make you aware your
contribution comes later on in this
chamber we don't
or a written reply from you like we do
with the statutory consultation so I
suppose the word confirmation comes
wrong but I think members will be aware
from time to time we have notified them
of the existence of an application and
that's what their toxic emotion report
means that's the one else in nature just
as a clarification it was to do with the
Western spur the officer saying that
this was likely to be potentially an
access onto the future development to
the West the reason we are because if it
is as basic to my way sake in the camp
this could potentially be on the record
yes though their numbers along as the
importance about pedestrian crossings
not just the traffic from the police
potentially traffic from the long
obviously cross it would be much more
important chairman the extension most
applications DuckTales
with the other escaped the you haven't
seen reserved matters yet have been
remaining part of the site i can't
confirm to you that it causes a wrap
around throat but i know for a fact that
highlights are happy with this
arrangement is a piece on the other side
preliminary discussions we've had we've
tracked the site on that so in the
fullness of time you would see the
pieces come together like a juice over
by the car confirming to there would be
a through groups I can confirm to this
our understanding I won't happy with
that arrangement
it's nice and
Thank You chairman I can't put my hands
on the exact passage when I read the
report
its focus board members not having
responding so I'm gonna have to refute
mr. strengths had to say this clearly
the council was looking for a response
from all members and it hasn't happened
I would also remind mr. strengths
respectfully that you mentioned mr.
Evans mentioned other developments one
in particular was the Christmas tree
farm development and yes as a member as
a ward member I was informed early on
and given access and written documents
for one of them and he says that we
should wait until this opportunity to
raise matters but I found him very
accommodating to wish to discuss things
during the prior to preparation that
report and indeed prior to the meeting
which was the alone meeting I had a
meeting with mr. strengths my Cobra wood
counselor and mr. strapp so there is
involvement by precedent for members
with developments so I don't think that
matter
in covered satisfactory to me Gemini's
they've supported the motion I believe
that there are matters that members
should quite properly wish to be
satisfied on personally in committee
rather than the things to offices to
move my condition the ones selected are
the ones that I would expect as a north
full-time member of this committee are
indeed a substitute to see to see
performed to my satisfaction I haven't
become aware of the construction of the
management agreement and I've had
several representations in different of
different sorts particularly with regard
to the other the other site which is B
major it dovetails that there is concern
about the extent to which construction
traffic if not properly regulated what
was a great deal of additional
congestion and disruption so I'm
expecting to see a construction
management agreement which covers all
the usual things which is about wind the
site and the active when we expect
vehicles to turn up and not park in the
road awaiting access to the site finish
times weekends and
because a construction management
agreement only ever appears in a
condition at best I'd like to see it as
part of a legal agreement so that
residents are fully fully protected so
if the officers can tell me when I
finished where the issues of
construction college is is deadly and
performs the purpose of avoiding
disruption and congestion visibly
I'd be grateful finally we've been on
two pedestrian crossing I please support
everything that council alumnus would
answer mistake and indeed as a Newport
is also safe the linkage of bats
pedestrian crossing with the greater
this application is frankly not good
enough there are too many applications
that rely on other applications with
regard to infrastructure and is becoming
confused and in fact our MP is
incredibly incredibly confused as to
where the roundabout six with the other
so I'd like to see across requirement
through a section 106 which of course
becomes a legal agreement by Nature
thank you cheering you don't you in just
a moment as the highway with a motion
for deferment on on the table at the
moment I think what the exactly counsel
on a minute every members had an
opportunity to raise the initial points
so after council hoc ways spoken we'll
go to the boats on the deferment and
then we'll conclude the rest of the
debates yes and I'll come at you to sum
up cheer what
they talk about the
and they go through various calculations
to produce like some
to be true for our son perhaps the case
that this would not be something that
would have been part of the agreement
and therefore in the process of that
this is important to this to be
addressed my concern is that in relation
to a number of issues highlighted in
particular to do with the crossing that
we could be in danger of doing similar
things in relation to another important
aspect
you found myself in agreement with
number of temples right the issue of the
crossing as a matter of importance and
how impacts not just about future
development stuff though that on the
time of the publication
yeah
Jared that's the crossing has become
quite irrelevant quit in the discussion
tier class officers can actually help my
memory here a little bit there was an
application on a site fairly adjacent as
a site where there was some money set
aside and there was a lot of discussion
about crossing with one of six
agreements can you confirm whether that
one memory is correct there and whether
that still stands it's my first point
chairman the application I think members
and referring is the one for each
other's dysplasia 47 49 12 the legal
agreement to my recollection there's a
traffic island that was being sore being
staff and the pavement was being
enhanced on the southern side because I
think it stops at this road here and
this crisscross photos members you went
on the site visit that day I think
member weekly trips a lot on the bird
for me throwing out the reservation my
recollections are that isn't a
full-blown etc the idea is that it's
beefing up to see the pavement but I
haven't got that information in detail
for you tonight on my brain it's it's a
central refuge that I was in Lansing
thank you yeah my memory is there was a
lot of discussion around that particular
point perhaps that can be pursued a
little bit further help with the cast at
the funcomfortable there's nothing there
that I've heard that card either be
sorted out by tradition or in
consultation with the war counselors
once the applications
great I can't agree to the deferment I
think it's just be dealt with my
condition thank you I too agree agree
with you I believe that compliance has
been demonstrated while warned the
principle items under conditions that
don't cover the rest I believe that
although the crossing is a significant
issue it's not within our remit to
determine that on that's Essex you
haven't requested it and the local
highways panel is it is going to be
looking at it important as it is careful
mrs. Mason would you like to sum up
that's before there be many concerns
raised exactly
patient and it is regrettable it's
comfort us in this state and it was
measured quite strongly last time and it
should have been perhaps better say that
a month later the same situation we are
where we are
the reason on moving for deferment is
because of a lack of construction
management agreements the information on
the inflection points I know it's
probably taking firmly should be
important to us before submit any
concerns laptops imitated other
properties we couldn't considered that
the design and access statement has
concerns that some of the golden
afternoon one of the Gothic says it's
unusable although the area is set to him
within armies it said that the governor
cited unusable some off street parking
has been again in there it says is look
appears to be an accessible thing that
we're providing for parking but we can't
because into the lighting knuckle
gliding provisional on the street the
design access concerns have not been
addressed and either orbit recommend is
included in positions the black and this
is an important for any sleep surface
water runoff during construction and
collusion has not been covered in
conditions it's something that has been
experienced on other sites and I do
think that's an important point that the
members should have the opportunity to
and last but not least there has been no
determination of safe walking it's
lightning routes to schools and the
clarification over the possible division
of a crossing has the mud would at best
and needs to be examined with all
counselors so
mr. Thomas to just make some comments
before thank you Jim it's just a couple
of points to make before members vote on
this particular matter I would reiterate
and in my advisory role here that this
is a policy compliant skin that is in
line with development plan and all
aspects of the skin meet criteria and
guidance that is set out in local
national policy to address some of the
points this matter related to the Dean
collection I would advise members that
this has been addressed appropriately by
the applicant as far as anything related
to lighting scheme that is conditioned
in the document as far as the crossing
is concerned that has been addressed by
Essex highways and it has not been
deemed necessary for this scheme for a
construction management plan that is
also being conditioned in relation to
drainage and runoff during construction
periods that has also been conditioned
and that is an appropriate way of
addressing that matter in relation to
affordable housing particularly it meets
the council's policy for 35%
housing who meets the policy and is
acceptable to our housing apartment with
the criteria presented in relation to
just see the lost matters
I think that's all the makers covered in
this in relation to parking is probably
the last one they meet me up our
standards completely and it's perfectly
acceptable to Essex highways so just
just to reiterate that point that it
meets the Apella standards the scheme
members vote now is on this item is
deferred not whether it is whether it's
approved or not just on even out the
obvious what it should be amendment
debate like to say in the report it says
that some of the off street parking is
in assessable so your mother say
apologies or not you can take those
points further it depending on which way
this next vote goes so members the vote
is to defer this item based on the items
for discussion that counselor mrs. Mason
has forward we've heard our professional
officer opinion those members in favor
of the deferment please indicate in fact
those against the deferment
motion to deferment is lost without
continue before we are really done that
the area that's in question
swallow the critiques as far as the IAM
site and comes close discipline marriage
very far away from where this is and
that we already know that a lot of the
Walter piece and I've walked around the
quiet bills the football fields and
what-have-you and at times they can't
even play football so the reason great
deal of water in their area and that's
the piece more cleaning the attention to
this judicial law in in relative to that
area is well now that the price for us
when it does it's very very bad in fact
you don't even get their growth so the
police stop anybody going that way I'm
taking round boys so and it's not 1 in
100 years and one in 30 years it has
done so in the past 3 years
consecutively flooding so how is this
newspaper going to get off of his salat
and make a boat to get off and one cop
didn't make a boat and how you wanted me
today just by holding you can't hold the
water back you simply float so you can't
hold me back and the whole point of this
exercise these yeah that's something
here first before you start I just want
you still be there that's the specter
just questions what is really it's been
a number of it it's issues concerns
raised our any of those concerns range
not even covered by the conditions or
the can't be feel grieved by
consultation with the more counselor and
develop it I feel the draft will be more
than happy to work work with more
councils on there were there any look
that were cabin
just on these points begin with please
I'll just I I don't have to read this to
terrible situation the summary of the
Provost assessment as the site has been
allocated for development by the local
planning authority the sequential test
does not have to be applied if sections
has to be successfully applied the
government proposal so basically the
crux of this matter is informed by
detour 1d 2d payroll or hydro on
hydraulic multiple barabra the roadblock
developed specifically to assess the
progress towards development ground
floor levels be sacked from the new
level of thirteen point two one point
above Orleans theta a not point six
meters of other model one percent and
your lens probability of flooding when
allowing for the upper end estimate of
the impact of climate change so
basically the the modeling has looked at
every scenario these the situation we
have here is we have cuts a tree
Constantine's look at the theater and do
not princess what the
the conclusions of global analysis is
and back on the basis of the of the
Environment Agency's people of the
flooding risk obviously that is material
fact has been established through and
demonstrated through the modeling
analysis has been undertaken okay can't
sustain me I think I'll give it up in
generous enough to get you know counts
of Sunday this I can understand me
please I've given you more than enough
opportunity to explore and restate your
concerns the officer has come back with
an opinion that we've got the reports
and I think the point the point is made
the finer detail can that can happen
elsewhere about the amount I've given to
you miss division it's like an ocean
thing I've got no other members
indicating to speak at the moment
therefore
I would like to discipline most on the
fact of the conditions and
transformation have a point of order but
we're not asking for officers conduct
we've had a presentation question for my
opponent agreed it's quite difficult how
to step down
they say in a nutshell the conditional
ever reason if you know it's not unusual
to have number of conditions on the
planning consent as I previously
indicated and to answer the question
incorrectly is but there isn't a matter
than a problem cannot be dealt with my
condition okay
they're members we've had a thorough
debate on this one and zito there is a
recommendation starting on page six
point 100 there is additional revised
recommendation on page 10 of the
addendum and there was also mention of
the Rayleigh's sports and social and
clever than the car parking issue as
well so members can I ask if we go to
the boat now please and as for those
members in favor of approval please
indicate
okay thank you
that's awesome days proved concludes our
meeting poll this evening